Merhaba ben yapay Yüceler Aslı arkada
yazılı video Şu an belki birçoğunuz
arkamdaki şeye Bakıyor Bu nedir Ne ile
çıktı Hatta genç arkadaş kitlesine sahip
olduğumuz için bu duşunu bile üye olan
olabilir acaba çekmediği için anten bir
taktı Hayır Arkadaşlar bunun içerisinde
Aslında ne olduğunu size şöyle söylesem
Her iki kişiden birine buraya girmeden
önce bu bilgiyi verdim desem Muhtemelen
Şu an herkes birbirlerine sana bu
bilgiyi verdiğini sana bu bilgiyi verdim
diye soruyordur Peki olaya şu şekilde
anlatacak olursak bunun içinde
arkadaşlar Aslında uzaktan kumandalı bir
bomba var diye bilgi versen Muhtemelen
bunun gerçek olduğunu hisseden
arkadaşlar İslam oluşturacak şekilde
dışarıya kendilerini atarlar ama size
şöyle desem Aslında Siz bu bilgiyi Bunun
içerisinde bu çantanın içerisinde bomba
olduğu bilgisini Dün elde ettiğimizi
bilseniz ne yapardınız şu an bu salona
gelmezsiniz Aslında İstihbaratta böyle
bir şey yani olaya buradan baktığınız
zaman bir
işin merak edebilmek iki gerçekten doğru
zamanda doğru şeyi öğrenebilmek Bu arada
Bunun içerisinde bir bomba filan yok
arkadaşlar sadece benim gol kromun
antenini sabah evden çıkarken Ne
anlatsam diye düşündüğümde şöyle
koyduğum için bugün böyle gezmeyeceğim o
yüzden bunu çıkarmak istiyorum
Şimdi arkadaşlar Bir de tabii Olaya
şöyle bakalım hepimiz Amerikan filmleri
izliyoruz istihbarat filmleri izliyoruz
ve orada çeşitli senaryolarla
karşılaşıyoruz işte bir James Bond benim
gibi giyinen işte böyle kişileri
görüyoruz ve onları kahramanlık
hikayelerini bulunuyoruz hatta her hafta
biliyorsunuz ki Dünyamız terör
saldırılarından kurtuluyor ama olayı
bile şöyle bakacak olursak bu adamlar
bunu nasıl yapıyor diye gerçekten bir
istihbaratı elde etmek içindeki en
önemli kaynaklardan bir tanesi olay
olduğu zaman Öğrenmek değil olaydan çok
öncesinde bunu öğrenip eğlen planına
geçebilmek nasıl doğum örneğini asla
verdiğim gibi şimdi Amerika'nın 1950'li
yıllarda seyir ajandan yetiştirirken
gidiyorlar Burada gördüğünüz John adlı
illüzyonisti diyorlar ki ya sen çok
hızlı hareketler yapabiliyorsun işte
şapkadan tavşan çıkartabiliyorsun
bu şekilde karakteri bürünebiliyorsun
kıyafetler değiştirebiliyorsun gel bizim
ajanlarımızla bunları öğrettiği 1950'li
yıllarda bu tür yan sanat dallarında
etkilenecek yeni fikirler oluşturuyorlar
ve ondan sonra bu ajanları piyasaya
sunuyorlar Hatta bir diğer noktalardan
bir tanesi
bu akustik kiti dediğimiz Bir
Operasyon Var Arkadaşlar bu operasyon
yapıyoruz daha interaktif bir şeyler
yapalım diyor bir tane kediyi alalım Bu
kediye üzerine bir dinleyici
yerleştiriliyor ve dinlemek istediğimiz
ortama bu kediyi gönderelim diyorlar
sonra Tamam her şey güzel bunu gerçekten
prototipini yapmak istedikleri zaman ne
oluyor biliyor musunuz
kedi karşıdan karşıya geçerken araba
kediyi eziyor ve programı rafa
kaldırıyorlar buradaki Önemli olan nokta
bir şeyleri deniyor olmaları Aslında
istihbarat anlamında bir yerlerde bilgi
var çünkü kendilerini savunmak için bir
yerlerden bilgi almaları gerekiyor ve
bunun içinde yöntemler geliştiriyor Peki
tarihte sonra nereye evlilik diye
baktığımız zaman da arkadaşlar
hepimizin de bildiği gurur duyduğu
iddialı sığmalar var Buradaki amaç ne
yükseklik faaliyeti farklı bir şekilde
düşmanı radar sistemlerine girmeden
istihbaratı bir bilgiyi alabiliyor veya
gerekli değilse de hele ki yok etme
yetkinliğine eşleştirebilecek
teknolojiler üretiyor Peki bu istihbarat
yapılarının bunları bu teknolojilerini
dikkat ederek en büyük sebeplerinden bir
tanesini arkadaşlar Aslında iki sebebi
var birinci sebep sürekli karşı taraf
defansif bir önlem uyguladığı için
onların geliştirdikleri yöntemlere
farklı yöntemler denemeleri gerekiyor
İkinci nokta ise
bir ajanın yetişmesi işte 1 ile 20 yıl
arasında oluyorsa bu kadar beklemeye
zaman yok çünkü hızlı bir bilgiye
Ulaşılması gerekiyor ve teknolojik
gelişmelere ayak uydurmaları gerekiyor
daha her zaman bir üst seviyeye
çıkmaları gerektiği için şimdi Aslında
Siber dünyada biraz bu şekilde gerçek bu
istihbaratif faaliyetleri Siber
dünyadaki mevzusu da aslında birbiriyle
aynı nedir şirketler bir yatırım yapıyor
diyorlar ki bir şeyi Biz daha hızlı
yapmak için evrilmemiz lazım dijital
dönüşümü ayak uydurmamız lazım Yani
normalde 1000 tane fabrikada Bir
fabrikanın çalışanları fabrikalara
baktığınız zaman diyorlar ki yani Biz
bunu yüze nasıl üreriz diyorlar ki ya
işte robotik süreçleri de öyle yapmamız
lazım teknolojiyi daha fazla kullanmamız
lazım işte kaliteli insan kaynağını
yetiştirmemiz için biraz önce dediğim
gibi
almamız lazım diyorlar Ondan sonra ama
bunların her biri Aslında bu
dönüşümlerin her biri dijital dünyada
internette ayak izleri bırakıyor şimdi
Tabii ki bu bir savaş başında da
söylediğimiz gibi bu savaşı ayak
uydurmak için de saldırganlar o dijital
izleri takip etmeye başlıyor Yani
robotik artık daha kapalı devre
hayatınızda yaşıyorken Fabrikalar
holdingler veya kişisel olarak baz alın
Yani kişisel olarak da baz aldığımız
zaman biliyorsunuz Eskiden fotoğraf
çektiğiniz zaman fotoğraf makinaları
vardır fotoğrafçıya götürdünüz 50 tane
toz şekerimiz Ondan sonra fotoğrafçının
der ki 3 gün sonra geldilerdi o 50 tane
fotoğrafını bir bakıyorsunuz 20 tanesi
yanlış 30 tanesi yanlış size falan
sadece elimizdeki O delik falan öyle bir
20 tane fotoğraf oluyor Ve bu da sizin
paylaşabileceğiniz bir nokta yokken
birden hayatınızda sosyal medya Ondan
sonra
veya
çeşitli platformlar devreye girdi Şimdi
peki Yani şöyle istatistiksel verilere
biraz baktığımız zaman her gün
arkadaşlar dakikada 20-30 tane mobil
uygulama devreye giriyor Peki bu mobil
uygulamalar neden devreye giriyor
Aslında bizlerin hayatını kolaylaştırmak
zamanla kazanabilmemiz için ama bir de
saldırganların bakış açısı var Şimdi siz
eskiden örnek veriyorum T.C kimlik
bilgileri Ondan sonra daha böyle
yanınızda taşıyabildiğiniz verilerken
yani devlet dairesinde işimiz olduğu
zaman o devlet dairesine gittiğinizde
sizden belirli evraklar isterdi sizin
götürdüğünüz evraklar ve devletin size
sağlıklılarıyla beraber
cüzdanı yenileme Neyse bu tür verileri
sizlerle paylaşırlardı Ama artık Ne oldu
bu işi kolaylaştıracak e-devlet gibi
sistemler devreye girdi işte hastane ile
ilgili uğraşıyorsanız İşte o sıra
bekleme olayı yine ortada kaldırmak için
rezervasyon sistemleri ile ilişki Siz
orada ne yaptınız iyidir biraz o
platformlara girdiniz ve hal böyle
olunca Aslında dijital dünyada birçok
ayak izinizi bırakıyor haline geldi
şimdi arkada görmüş olduğunuz firmalara
baktığımız zaman bu dünyaların en büyük
bütçelere sahip firmalarından
bahsediyoruz ve bunlar çok ciddi
derecede hacklenme vakaları ile karşı
karşıya kaldı bunun en büyük
sebeplerinden bir tanesi yanlış yatırım
yapmaları ile alakalı değil arkadaşlar
bunlarla milyon dolarlar bile güvenmeye
getiremedim defansif anlamda sistemlerin
korumak için güvenliğe yatırım
yapıyorlar ama göz öyle bir faktör var
insan faktörü Sizler Bizler Neden Çünkü
siz bir mobil uygulama hayatınızı
kolaylaştıracak olduğu bir uygulamayı
Dediğiniz zaman en basit örneğinden
Biraz önce akustik kiti örneğini verdim
kedi örneğinin ne yapıyordu ki ortamı
dinlemeye çalışıyordu artık ona gerek
kalmadı Neden Çünkü kullandığımız sosyal
medya platform ların Instagram'ı
kullanıyorsunuz Facebook Bunlar benim
mobil uygulamalar var sadece oradan bir
izin vere tıkladığınız zaman hep
şunlarla karşı karşıya kalıyorsunuz Ya
ben 30 defa işte şunu söyledim ortamda
beni dinledi Instagram bunun
karşılığında bunu bir reklam çıkardı
hepinizin karşısına
konuşuyorsunuz kafe ile ilgili reklam
geliyor kedi maması konuşuyorsunuz kedi
maması ile alakalı reklam geliyor artık
bunun için ortamda gerçekten fiziksel
bir kediye ihtiyaç yok Sizin sadece cep
telefonunuza sirayet etmeleri yeterli
Peki saldırganlar bunu nasıl yapıyor
size sosyal mühendislik yöntemi ile
ilgili işte siz İnstagram
kullanıyorsunuz bir bakıyorsunuz işte
Eğer bir biliyorsunuz Türkiye'de bir
yangın Vakası gerçekleşti oradaki
kampanya çıktı dediler ki orman
yangınları dediler onunla alakalı
kampanya yapıyoruz dediler ve siz orayı
doldurdunuzu kullanıcıların bu verileri
aldılar Şimdi siz diyorsunuz ki ya benim
verim alsa ne yapabilirim diye
bakıyorsunuz olaya ama Sibel dünyada
olay böyle geçiyor çünkü bir tane
dijital ayak izi çok kıymetli oluyor
Sizin bugün kullanmış olduğunuz paraları
belki birçok platformda aynı
kullanıyorsunuz Şimdi o platformlar aynı
kullandığınız zaman saldırganlar Sizin
cep telefonunuza veya bilgisayarınıza
sızdığı zaman o paralı topluyor veya
bilgileri topluyor Türkiye'nin
karakteristik hareketliliğini çıkartıyor
Türkiye ne ile uğraşıyor Türkiye'deki
Neyi bir duymak istiyor bunları
çıkartıyor biliyorsunuz ki trump'ın
Amerika seçimlerini kazanmasını en büyük
sebebi Facebook'tan Hani bölgeye göre
Aslında insanlar o bölgede ne konuşuyor
Onu öğreniyor onu öğrendikten sonra o
bölgeye gittiği zaman ona göre seçim
kampanyası yapıyor şimdi
Biz Sibel İstihbaratta neler yapıyoruz
aslında Siber istihbarat dediğiniz olay
bir takım oyunu arkadaşlar Çünkü
uğraştığımız noktalara baktığınız zaman
Siber suçlularla uğraşıyorsunuz hack
Twister ile kötü niyetli ülkelerle Çünkü
ülkeler birbirlerini artık şunu görür ya
Ben bir yere füze atmak yerine ben
gideyim o ülkeyi Siber olduğum olsun bu
sefer orduyla onları sistemlerine ele
geçiriyor Burada iki tane faktör devreye
giriyor o fansız
sekreterini hepimiz dönüştürüyoruz
hackerlar hacker olmak hacker nasıl
olunur gibi kavramları hepimiz duymuşsun
ama bir de bunun karşılığında buna
defans sağlayacak kitle var yani o bahsi
bir bakış açısı var bir defa sizi bir
bakış açısı var bir de şirketler artık
şunu demeye başladı ya biz bu kadar
bekleniyoruz bu kadar yatırım yapıyoruz
bunun neticesinde Halen neden buralardan
koyuyoruz diye baktıklarında şunu tespit
ettiler Yani bir Siber kullanıyorum
önüne geçelim ve gerçekten firmalarla
anlaşalım ve bizi sanki bir Siber suçlu
gibi baksak istihbaratı verilerimizi
toplasın istihbarattaki verilerdeki
kasları sizi son kullanıcıların içinde
sizleri şirkette çalışıyorsunuz kişisel
bilgisayarınıza sirayet ediyor ve orada
diyelim ki kullandığımız bir parola var
Onu oradan alıyor diyor ki ya bu parola
Belki de şirketteki mail adresi
fazlasıyla aynıdır diyor ve oradaki
veriyi buralarda kullanıyor veya sizden
aldığı veriyi de sizin işte bir tekleme
yapıyorsunuz şu an bodrumda tatil değil
mi diye ailemle Tatildeyim diyor fark
bir şekilde
saldırganlar evinize gelecek hırsız buna
bakıyor al diyor Şu an bu aile Bodrum'da
tatildir demek bunların evinde şu an
kimse yok varımla çıkartıp sizin evinize
ki bunu Biz fazlasıyla yaşadık
arkadaşlar Böyle bakanlarla karşılaştım
Hatta bir tane vakada saldırgan şunu
yapıyor bir bizzat fiziki Hırsız eve
giriyor ondan sonra altınları çalıyor
aile o an gelirken evden erken çıkıyor
ve sonra arıyor aradan İki gün sonra ya
ben çok pişman oldum Ben şu an içtiği
yerdeyim Gelin size altınlarınızı
vereceğim diyor aile oraya gittiğimde
eve bir daha geliyor ve gerçekten işinin
devamını yapıyor şimdi gerçekten bir
gerçek senaryodan bahsediyorlar
arkadaşlar
tabi Şöyle bir istatistik var İnsanların
ve saldırganlar bu Siber istihbarat
dediğimiz dünyada boş durmuyorlar
Alevilik düşünceyle yaklaşıyorlar neler
yapıyorlar Ondan sonra siz ne yersiniz
ne içersiniz Algoritma çıkartıyorlar ve
sonra şunu bulabilirler Yani insanlar
aslında yüzde 51'i bir parolayı Birçok
yerde kullanıyor bu inanılmaz bir Çünkü
Sibel suçlular daha çok görülmeyeni
görmeye çalışırlar en önemli noktalardan
bir tanesi bu şimdi Siber saldırganlar
Siber suçlular işte Hikmet dediğimiz
platformlar var yani darp işte
internetin görülmeyen yüzü dediğimiz
işte böyle belirli linkiler üzerinde
belirli bir kullanıcının
olarak Bizler onlar gibi davranmaya
çalışıyoruz hani en başında dedim ki bir
tane de bizde valiz var ondan kılıf
değiştirmeye öğreniyor Aslında bu süreç
istihbaratla uğraşan arkadaşlarımız
genellikle saldırganlara yaranmaya
çalışırlar onların içine girmeye
çalışıyorlar Çünkü neden amac ımızı
bomba patlamadan önce kaç gün önce
bulabilmek onların evinde ne gibi
nereye Hedef alıyorlar işte bu tecrübeye
sahip olmak için hep ofansif bakış
açısına ihtiyacınız var Her defasında
ihtiyacımız hem bilim ve sanata
ihtiyacınız var Neden Çünkü biraz önce
hanımefendi burada ne yaptı sizden
kelimeler topladı bir şarkı ortaya
çıkardı yani orada bir inovasyon yaptı
Şimdi bu inovasyona aslında Siri
istihbarat yapıyorken de kullanmanız
gerekiyor hayali gücünüze gerçekten çok
ihtiyacınız var ki Türkiye'nin yüzde iki
hayal gücüyle çocukların düşündüğü oranı
%2 imiş arkadaşlar hani ne olmak
istiyorsun diye sorduklarında Doktor
işte XZ diye o mesleki alanlara
çıkarttığın zaman hayal gücünü almak
Bize geldiği zaman ona cevap verebilmek
%2 olduğunu düşünürsek burada Hayal
gücümüze inanılmaz bir önem arz ediyor
Şimdi peki Benim Hayat hikayemlerde
başladı bu Amerika'da Amerika'ya
gittiğim zaman Arkadaşlar bir arabam
vardı arabanın sattım Orada işte belki
Üniversitesi'nde bir programa dahil
oldum ondan sonra bir yerlerde çalışmam
gerekiyordu Amerika'da
[Müzik]
etrafındaki 5 kişinin ortalaması
kadardır diye bir laf vardır sonra ben
dedim ki ya etrafıma birkaç kişiyi
toplamam gerekiyor Sonra araştırmalarıma
devam ettim hepimiz demiş gibi izlemişiz
işte 300 Spartalı Ondan sonra Game Of
thrones'teki İşte Ölüler ordusuna karşı
Hayat ekipler bilmem ne o orduyu falan
hep izlemişizdir ama Mesela şöyle
şeylerle de karşılaşıyor araştırma
hayatım boyunca İşte bin tatlı Akıncı
çocuklar gibi bir adlı
o gün bir hafta bugün bir olguyu
Devirdik falan gibi böyle bir Akıncılar
duyan oldu mu daha önce
nereden kaynaklandığını biliyorsunuz
[Müzik]
herhangi bir şey ortaya çıkmıyor ha
dedim burada o zaman beni doğru bir
delil bir takım olacak benim konsantre
çalışıyor olmam lazım Daha efektif neler
yapabilirim Çünkü 1+1 toplarsanız iki
eder ama bir artı bir yanı getirirseniz
11 eder işte Buradaki en önemli nokta
Benim bugün vurgulamak istediğim Siber
dünyamda olsun kişisel hayatınızda olsun
en önemli nokta 11 olabilmek Arkadaşlar
etrafınızdaki bir kişi iki
[Müzik]
55 kişiyiz arkadaşlar şirkette dünya
kupası
Dünya Kupasını izleyenler Muhtemelen
vardı Dünya Kupası bütün Sibel
istihbarat süreçlerini Bizler yaptık
Türkiye'den Türk bir şekilde arkadaşlar
Evet Amerika'dan yatırım aldık ama
buradaki gücü kullanarak aldık ben işte
beyin göçü falan bunlar Evet arkadaşlar
coğrafya Kaderde değilseniz o
diyebilirsiniz ama düzeltip teknolojisi
bulunduğu lokasyonun önemi yok Önemli
olan yapacağın iş ve doğru orantılı
zaten kaliteli işin ortaya çıkarttığınız
zaman o 11 olabilirsiniz 111
olabilirsiniz mutlaka sizi birileri
buluyor FBI ile ortak operasyonlar
düzenliyoruz Güney Kore Güney Kore
Cumhuriyeti'nin savunma sanayisi ile
ortak operasyonlar düzenlenir Türkiye
Cumhuriyeti'nde Türk kurum operasyonlar
düzenliyoruz Tabii ki ortak operasyon
döneminde şampiyona takıp gitmiyoruz
yani siberalemde siber
[Müzik]
[Alkış]